donc il va falloir s'équiper de basket
et faire marcher ses neurones et oui le
centre alfred de vigny vous emmène en
balade au coeur de la ville de
voisins-le-bretonneux trois heures et 6
km pour un rallye pédestre sur la piste
d'alfred une grande promenade pour
partir à la découverte de tous les
petits chemins et les originalités de la
ville des épreuves et des questionnaires
vont rythmer cette balade
il faut surtout bien se mettre dans la
tête que c'est quelque chose qui fait
pour s'amuser
donc il y aura une bonne dose d'humour
qui en espère aussi beaucoup de temps
agréable se promener observé surtout
observé parce que beaucoup de gens
lorsqu'ils sont dans la ville ont
tendance uniquement à regarder leur
quotidien et pas s'apercevoir qu'il y a
plein de petits détails et c'est une
découverte avec un thème et oui les
baisers participants dont se
familiariser que les animaux il va donc
falloir chercher des aliments ou des
symboles qui les représente dans la
ville les équipes vous ont concocté un
petit parcours qui débute au centre
alfred devinez qui passe notamment par
la mairie et qui revient vers le centre
et les inscriptions se font par équipes
alors les équipes
histoire de dire c'est entre amis et en
famille alors pas d'inquiétude si vous
pensez être peu nombreux
une équipe des buts des deux personnes
pas de compétition mais des surprises
vous attendront à l'arrivée il faut
s'inscrire par contre c'est d'ici le
samedi 20 mais il reste encore de la
place dans ses 26 mai je sais pas ce que
je dis mais il reste encore de la place
et c'est le samedi 2 juin la date du
rallye alors profitez-en vous entre vous
entraîner à bien d'ouvrir les yeux merci
beaucoup mais la nier